- It's like a cat.
It'll just walk all over
you and not give any shits.
(upbeat music)
- Why is that moving?
- Where are they?
- In here?
- Open this door right here?
- Oh shit!
(laughing)
- Oh my God!
Hello!
- No, no, no, no!
Oh there's something else in there!
Oh shit, it's a tail!
(laughing)
Eww, they're gross!
- Oh, I think they're
kinda cute!
- What are you eating?
Cheers!
- How do you hold this?
- What's up?
- I've got like, 50 Shades
of Grey happening here.
Hello!
Hello, friend!
(grunting)
- No way!
- If I knew one as a baby
and we were best friends,
then I could see this being a pet for me.
- I feel like a serial killer.
"Hey everybody.
"Wanna come see something cute?"
- Rats are like, misunderstood.
- Now these two are sleeping
on top of each other.
Do you like being under a butt?
- I feel like a pirate with
a parrot on my shoulder.
- Wait, ew its tail!
(grunting) Oh my God, his
tail is going in my mouth!
- I'm done.
- How come these are
different from sewer rats?
- Now we know they are just
little, perfect babies!
- Do I look couture?
Does it look couture?
I'm like weirdly okay with this.
We're best friends now.
See?
What's it doing?
It's going in my shirt!
Cleo, I swear to God if you
poop in my hair right now!
- It's here! It's here.
- [All] It's here!
- It's here!
- It's here.
- Get it!
- There!
- I think they got it. Get it!
- Get it!
- Yeah, you get it.
- It's here!